Film Courage: Is the director always the first
one on set?
Would you ever see other crew members or actors
show up before you?
If so, what did that say about them?
Bill Duke: Some actors (I won’t mention
their names) but they are so involved in the
legitimacy of what they do.
They are there before the crew and me.
They just sit on the set and sit in the seat
and they know they’re…if it’s supposed
to be their bedroom, they’ll go in the bedroom
and touch the props, they’ll become familiar
with the pictures on the wall, what’s in
the closet?
What kind of bed sheets are there?
What color are they?
How soft are they pillows and why those pillows
are that soft or why are they harder?
Is the blind closed are is it open?
Are there curtains on the wall?
And why was that color chosen for the sheet?
“Aaahh, okay…”
And they’re comfortable because it’s their
bedroom for the last 15 years.
So sometimes they come to set two days before
and they just sit there and they become organically
ingrained.
Some of the great actors have their own way
of becoming the truth of what they are supposed
to be.
And I get there and they are like “Hey,
Bill.”
“What you doing here?”
“You know what I’m doing?”
“You know what I’m doing…working.”
“I see and thank you, because I respect
that.”
They don’t just wait for you to tell them
what to do…they have their own because I’m
an actor, too.
As you start surrendering to a character that
they author has written, it’s going to sound
crazy but the character tries to live through
you if you accept him or her.
I was playing a character once in a movie
(I forgot which one it was) and a week before
I was supposed to film, I started doing this
[makes noises with his mouth].
Never done that in my life.
My girlfriend at the time said “What are
you doing?”
I said “What are you?”
She said “You’re going…[makes noises
with mouth].”
I said “No, I’m not.”
She said okay.
Five minutes later I’m going…[makes noises
with his mouth].
And that was the character coming through
me and so I put that in part of the film because
I knew something that was being expressed
through that person.
And it’s trust.
Trusting your instincts, yourself and your
talent.
Film Courage: So if an actor once to do all
of those things, bring little idiosyncrasies,
ticks or show up three hours early, is something
they feel they need permission to do?
Because I could see a new actor wanting to
do those things but being scared because they
don’t want to offend anybody or whatever.
Bill Duke: If you’re a new actor and you
know what acting is and you have a good director,
he’ll give you the permission that you need,
to be the best you can.
Good directors…their ego…if I’m shooting
a scene with the star of the movie in a car
and we shot half this scene before lunch and
we shoot half the scene after lunch.
And an intern, an assistant or a caterer comes
up to me and says “Hey, Bill, Bill…”
And I say “What?”
“The license plate before you went to lunch
was straight but now it’s crooked.
I don’t say “You’re the caterer.
You’re an assistant.
Mind your own business.”
That’s stupid!
I say “Thank you very much because I didn’t
see that.”
And I have my assistant go and straighten
up the license plate.
You know why?
Because I still get directing credit.
That person is no less than me.
That person helped me out.
But some people throw phones at….I don’t
understand these idiots.
Throwing phones in people’s faces and this
royalty wave like they are superior to human
beings and an attitude of superiority like
people are…it’s annoying.
Because they are all going to die.
They all bleed.
And I do believe (I have no proof of course.
I don’t want it) that when they all go to
the bathroom and do Number 2, they stink.
And if they don’t…if they can prove they
don’t stink when they go to the bathroom,
I will worship them.
But until that moment occurs, don’t come
to me with that crap.
You understand?
You stink, I stink, we both stink.
Cool.
Do your damn job.
Simple.
Film Courage: We’re going to assume that
they stink.
Bill Duke: If you’re asking me if I’m
going to the bathroom, I’m not.
Film Courage: We will air on the side of caution.
Bill Duke: Great caution!
Film Courage: Nice pun, too.
Air.
Bill Duke: Air.
See I like that what she said.
Air…Air.